Okay. The last thing I want to talk about with regard
to update, is how to update multiple documents at once.
There are many situations in which we want to do
some sort of global modification to all documents matching a
certain set of criteria. So, here we selected a single
document, and updated its country code to DEU. And updated
it so that it included this country code. But this
is a country code, not a city code. And we
could go into why we would want to do this. This
is definitely a de-normalization of this data, if you're familiar with
that term. Essentially where we headed here with this example,
is that the country code will be replicated in every single
document that represents the city in Germany. In Mongo DB,
we design our document schemas so that they match the access
patterns. So that ideally, in order to satisfy any one query,
you only have to hit the database once. Therefore the normalization
makes sense. It's a way of getting really hyper formats
and being able to scale really well, your database. Okay,
pardon the slight digression, but I assume that for at
least a few of you, the normalized versus denormalized data
question was coming to mind. Okay, back to the topic
at hand. In this case, what I'd like to do,
is use update to query for documents whose country is
Germany. And what I'd like to do is set the isoCountryCode
field for all such documents to this value. The way we do that using update,
is by specifying a 3rd parameter, multi equals
true. Now by default again, update will modify
just the first document that it finds. So, in order to get it to modify
all documents matching this query, we need to
specify this parameter. Okay, so let's run this.
Okay, and then, we can go back to the Mongo
shell and do a query. Now, this time, I need
to modify my query so that we're looking for all
cities with the country field of Germany. And because we want
them all, I need to change this back to a
Find, instead FindOne. Right? And then I want to pretty
print these, and here we go. Here is Chemnitz, hope
I'm pronouncing that properly. And it has the correct I.S.O. code,
and here we have another city, with the correct country
code and so on as we move through this data.
Okay, so that's multiple update and of course we could
use other operators besides just set in this same way.